Today.
I wanted to begin with that
question I left you with.
Um,
what does housekeeping have
to do with the identity plot?
Did you see elements of the
identity plot in this novel?
Who did?
Okay.
And what did you see? Yes.
What did you see? Oh yeah. Oh,
now you have to, you
have to make good. Yes.
MMM.
You going, I can come
back to you. Yes, I would.
I would be quite happy to do that.
Is someone else more ready to say what
this novel has to do with the identity
pot?
Yes.
Well,
I wouldn't leave speaking Ruth struggles
with her own identity and how to fit it
into societal conceptions of what
it means to be a normal person
and function.
Absolutely. And what
details for you most, um,
mark that conflict in Ruth?
Where do you see that happening?
Can you see it a lot in her care?
Ah Huh.
In her hair and her dress? Yes.
So you see, by contrast with Ruth,
you see Lucille doing a
lot of work on her hair,
trying to make clothes,
um,
becoming close with the
home economics teacher, uh,
chiding Ruth for not looking normal
than they walked down the street.
Um,
so you really do see it in that dynamic,
especially between the two sisters
and as you say, and clothes and hair.
Where else do you see this?
Yeah,
that sense of being at odds is one
part of it. Where else do you see it?
Okay. You're not talkative today.
Let's try something easier.
I'd like to read the first
sentence of the novel.
Yeah.
My name is Ruth.
What can we say about that sentence
as the opening sentence of a novel?
Any thoughts or observations about it?
Yes.
Yes, it absolutely does. And
what's the first line of Moby Dick?
Call me. Oh, in chorus.
That was beautiful.
So you may have read Moby Dick
even if he didn't read this. Um, so
call me Ishmael. Okay. Absolutely.
Marilyn Robinson as is going to emerge
in my lecture today is very much
preoccupied with the 19th century.
She is very interested,
especially in these classic American
writers of the American transcendental
school, and that's Melville,
Hawthorne, Emerson.
I'm also very interested in Dickinson,
Emily Dickinson.
She has a sensibility that
maps very closely with theirs,
and I'll get into that towards
the end of of my lecture today,
but just as a narrative strategy,
how is call me Ishmael
different from my name is Ruth.
You would have ideas about that.
What do you,
what's different about
those two sentences?
Yeah,
we'll call me Ishmael.
Seems like it's more of a
choice on the characters' part.
Identify themselves [inaudible] is this
something that was given to her or not?
It wasn't something that she chose.
Okay, very good. Yeah, so Ishmael says,
here's what I want you to call me,
and Ruth says to us,
this is what people do call.
Yes.
What is interactive in
what is declarative?
Absolutely. Yes. So the
called me implies a you,
it reaches out of the text and
uses that implied second person.
You call me Ishmael.
My name is Ruth.
Simple declarative sentence.
It gives you that sense that
Ruth is more separate from you,
perhaps as a reader.
Um,
then Ishmael is Ishmael wants
to enter into dialogue with you,
wants you to reach out towards him.
Ruth offers you herself as something
like the object of contemplation or a
stranger as a stranger. That's
what a stranger says to you. Hi,
my name is Amy. Uh, that's the kind
of address a stranger gives you.
What else do you notice
about those two sentences?
Any other differences you can think of
or similarities even between the two?
Both those names. Ruth initial
male. Yes. Is your hand up?
Your hand is yes. Dangerously floating?
Yes. Actually I'll take yes. You,
yeah, absolutely. Both people call names
and they have certain similarities too.
Yes.
Uh, finish male. We're sort of a stranger
unit cultures that they lived in.
Absolutely.
Can you explain more about that?
Well,
um,
if mail was the first son of Abraham
that he was not really brought into the
family and eventually he was left in the
wilderness stories that from him spring
up the, uh, the Arabic tribes.
That's right. So He's Hagar
son. He is the son of Abraham's,
uh, is or, um, Sarah serving woman.
So He's, I, Abraham is unable
to conceive a child with Sarah.
So he sleeps with Hagar and Hagar
bears him, his son, Ishmael.
So he's from the family of Abraham,
but he's outside that family.
Now what about Ruth? Do
you want to continue? Yeah.
Ruth married into a Jewish family.
She herself with,
from a Jewish family. She
was from another tribe. Um,
but she went,
her husband died and her father in law
died instead of returning to her own
people,
she stayed with her mother in law.
That's right. So she stays
with her mother in law, Naomi,
and they go back to the land
of Judah. And there she, uh,
becomes known as a righteous woman,
a humble,
loving, and righteous woman. She is a
daughter to her mother in law. Naomi,
she in fact, stays with Naomi,
um, because she loves her.
There's this beautiful line,
uh,
when Naomi urges her to go back to
her own mother and stay in Moab,
her own land,
she says to Naomi,
where you go, I will go. It's probably
a line you've heard and it goes on.
It's a very beautiful,
actually meant to bring my Bible with me,
but I seem to have forgotten
it. Um, very beautiful line.
So it highlights her faithfulness.
It's faith to Naomi that brings her into
the realm of Judah under the protection
of the god of the Israelites and
causes her to become married to Boaz,
who was of a noble family.
And Ruth finally is the great
grandmother of King David.
So she is an alien,
a stranger who comes into the Israelite
fold and ends up being in the lineage of
their greatest king. And in
the New Testament, of course,
that also means that she is of the house
of Jesus because Jesus is of the House
of David.
So in Christian teaching,
the story of Ruth is about the
foreshadowing of the gentile inclusion
of the Jewish redemption.
So the Jewish Messiah
is the world's redeemer and
the presence of the alien,
the stranger in his bloodline suggests
that expansion of the promise.
So Ruth is a very important character.
She is identified both by her status as
a stranger and by her absolute central
valley to a strong identity,
either as Israel light or as Christian.
So in these two versions of these,
this story of lineage,
it is no accident that this is
the name that Robinson chosen for,
for this character.
Um,
lots of elements of that
story enter into Ruth's story.
So Ruth,
like her namesake cleaves
to a woman relative,
and this is Sylvie Shi Shi cleaves
to and becomes faithful to Sylvie,
her aunt in place of her own mother.
So there is an exchange as in the biblical
story between the mother that she has
lost this in this novel through
the mother's suicide. Uh,
she's replaced with an aunt.
There's also that sense that she
follows the aunt into a wandering life.
So in the biblical story,
the wandering has a very clear end.
It's a wandering back to
the mother in law's land.
Back to Judah.
You will have to think about as
you get to the end of this novel,
whether there is an end to the wandering
in housekeeping or whether it is an
unmitigated wandering
related to that question is
another one about narrative.
And that is where does
this voice come from?
What account of this voice are we given?
Who is speaking to us and from
what position in the world?
This is a question, I will get a
two by the end of this lecture.
We will come to an
understanding of that question.
So
the biblical reference as well as the
male Villian reference suggests wandering
and it suggests a complex
picture of identity.
And I think that's what you get in the
novel that connects it to the conventions
of the identity pot.
So there's one element which is the
whole theme of Lucille and Ruth,
which uh, I was talking about
coming from your comment.
That's the simple version. There's
a more complicated version, um,
that I just want to show you on 96 97.
Okay.
This is when Lucille and Ruth
are playing hooky from school.
They've made their summer very long.
Starting in March,
I don't recommend this by the way.
Um,
and they are walking around by the
railroad tracks and they come upon some
hobos.
This top of 96 we in our plaid dresses
in Orlon sweaters and velveteen shoes and
they in their suit coats with the
vestigial collars turned and the lapels
closed.
Might have been marooned survivors
of some lost pleasure craft.
We and they alone might have escaped
the destruction of some sleek train.
That's an Ishmael Ishmael
reference right there.
Ishmael is the only person to escape the
p Quad to come back and tell the story.
So there's an element of that
Melville reference rate here too.
Some flying shuttle of
business or commerce.
Lucio and I might have been to have a
numerous family off to visit a grandmother
in lap.
Why?
And they might've been touring
legislators or members of a dance band.
Then our being there on a bigger
morning and ruined and unsuitable close
wordlessly looking at the water would
be entirely understandable as it was.
I thought of telling them that our
grandfathers still lay in a train that had
slid to the lake floor
long before we were born.
Perhaps we all awaited a resurrection.
Perhaps we expected a train to
leap out of the water caboose.
Foremost as if in a movie run backward
and then to continue across the bridge,
the passengers would arrive sounder than
they departed accustomed to the depth
serene about the restoration to the light
disembarking at the station and finger
bone with a calm.
That quieted the astonishment of friends
say that this resurrection was general
enough to include my
grandmother and Helen.
My mother say that Hellen lifted our hair
from our napes with her cold hands and
gave us strawberries from her purse.
Say That my grandmother Peck Tower Browse
with her whiskery lips and then all of
them went down the road to our house,
my grandfather,
youngish and high pocketed just outside
their conversation like a difficult
memory or a ghost. Then Lucille
and I could run off to the woods,
leaving them to talk about old times and
make sandwiches for lunch and show each
other snapshots.
There's a lovely movement in that passage.
So first she moves from a fantasy that
would make the hobos and Lucille and
Ruth,
part of comprehensible holes,
comprehensible social groups,
going to identifiable places,
moving through spaces that made sense.
So if they were legislators,
members of a dance band or the girls
were part of some large family.
If they were all on some pleasure craft,
it would explain the inappropriateness
of their clothes and how they ruined if
there had been a disaster.
All these are ways of imagining a stable
and socially legible identity for all
the people in the scene,
Hobos and girls.
Then it slips into this moment where the
difference between Ruth and Lucille and
the Hobos is insisted upon when she says,
I thought as it was,
I thought of telling them that our
grandfathers still lay in a train that had
slid to the lake floor long before we
were born by turning to the Hobos and in
her mind addressing them.
She pushes them further away from
her and Lucille and begins to craft a
distinction between them.
They,
Ruth and Lucille are rooted in finger
bone by the very weight of their family
lying at the bottom of the lake.
So it gives them a rootedness to the
place that the Hobos can't claim.
The hobos transients is highlighted
by this imagined address to them
when
she further dreams of the
resurrection of the whole train,
all the family at the bottom of the lake.
It allows her to imagine herself
and Lucille in this warm,
coherent embrace in a more fulsome way.
So the family then isn't just imagined
to distinguish them from the Hobos,
but to imagine a more fully alive,
uh,
presence to her,
a family that will restore her
identity and her legibility to herself,
not just to the Hobos or
the town.
And I love this repeated structure,
verbal structure.
Say the proposition.
Say that Hellen lifted our hair,
a very intimate gesture.
Say That my grandmother picked her
brows with her whiskery lips so that it
invites us into the sensual
commerce of a family.
That's what she uses her imagination
to do. But then how it ends a,
you can't miss this.
Lucille and I could run off to the woods,
the restoration of the family.
The resurrection is precisely what then
will liberate them to do exactly what
they're doing now. Running off
to the woods, being truant.
So in this beautifully crafted passage
where we see Ruth's imagination moving
from one fantasy to another,
you see how the act of trying to
restore her own legibility through this
narrative,
through that repeated say the propositions
finally gets her back to where she
was before so that the restoration of a
secure identity in a family is in fact
what then propels her out to imagine
once again her separateness from it.
So what Robinson gives us,
I think in this version,
not so much in the story of Lucille and
Ruth and the difference between the two
of them,
which parses the problem as being those
who conform and can be legible to the
world and those who are not and have
to be separate from the social world.
Lucille goes to the home economics
teacher roof goes with Sylvie.
That's a very simple split.
This passage and the way Ruth's mind
works makes it much more complex.
So that it's the identity that
allows for the final alienation,
the identity or the security in the family
is what allows for the finding of one
separateness in the woods.
So there are two kinds
of identity at issue,
the single and the communal,
or we could say the
contemplative and the social.
I think it's ultimately the contemplative
or the singular person that interests
Robinson even more.
But I will say that in the
initial reception of this novel,
because the identity plot is so fixed
in the pattern of literary work in this
period,
and also fixed in the concerns of critics,
early readings of this novel,
really we're all about that
simpler version of identification.
People read this as a feminist novel
that was really all about women being
liberated from a confining domesticity
and finding their individual identity out
there in the world some other way.
So that housekeeping and it's rejection
where the major terms of the criticism
and if you've ever seen the film Fellman
Louise, you can sort of see the, uh,
the,
the way it chimes with a lot of what
was being thought in popular culture on
these questions.
You can think of Helen sailing
off the cliff into the lake,
so seamen as empowering in her car.
It did not take long for readers of this
novel to abandon that because of the
predominance of the themes that
I'm going to talk about next.
And that's the question of how can you
be a coherent person in this world?
What does that look like?
Ruth is very troubled by this quality.
It comes though in tiny ways like on 78
with other characters.
Lucille,
we are told is caught,
uh,
cheating by her teacher on a test.
Lucille was much too indifferent to school
ever to be guilty of teaching and it
was only an evil fate that had prompted
her to write Simone Bolivar and the girl
in front of her too,
right Simone Bolivar.
When the answer was
obviously General Santa Ana,
this was the only error either of them
made. And so their papers were identical.
Lucille was astonished to find that the
teacher was so easily convinced of her
guilt,
so immovable.
He persuaded of it calling her up in
front of the class and demanding that she
account for the identical papers.
Lucille rived under this
violation of her anonymity.
What does it mean to call that
instance of violation of her anonymity?
Well,
what's imagined here is that two minds
by some mysterious process sort of melded
with one another and
produce the same answers,
the exact identical exams.
Lucille is so easy with the
idea of that kind of melding
that she is stunned by being called out,
not as a violation of her honor,
but as a violation of her anonymity.
She wanted to be without name essentially.
That's what being anonymous means.
You're without a name,
you kind of blend in with the crowd.
That's exactly what she was doing when
her mind blended with that of the girl in
front of her and they produced identical
papers. It's a funny little logic.
It's a tiny detail that you can see now
rhyming with other details in the novel.
If you think of the conversation
between Lillian knownow, the two, um,
maiden aunts that take care
of the girls for a while,
that funny conversation on page 38,
um,
where essentially these are two women
who have totally melded into each other.
They say the same things.
Their conversations are just the ritual
assurance of a shared thread of thought.
Someone filled the teapot.
We're not even told which of them it is,
cause you can't even
really tell which it is.
Children are hard for anybody.
The Hartwick has always kept them out and
I understand that. I don't blame them.
No, no. And it goes on. Um,
these are two people who like
Lucille and the girl in front of her.
Their minds have melded
this time by long habit,
by long living together and
buy their love for each other.
It gets darker though on one oh five.
Okay.
It's hard as it turns out,
to maintain your separateness or to
maintain a sense that you really are an
entity as a person.
Okay.
Where's Lucille says Sylvie to
Ruth having woken up on a bench.
Yeah,
home says Ruth. Well,
that's fine. Sylvie said,
I'm glad to have a chance to talk to you.
You're so quiet.
It's hard to know what you think.
Sylvia had stood up and we began
to walk toward home. I suppose.
I don't know what I think this
confession embarrassed me.
It was a source of both terror and
comfort to me then that I often seemed
invisible incompletely or
minimally existent. In fact,
it seemed to me that I made no impact
on the world and that in exchange I was
privileged to watch it unawares,
but my allusion to this feeling of
ghostliness sounded peculiar and sweat
started all over my body, convicting
me on the spot of gross corporeality.
Well, maybe that will change. Sylvie
said, we walked a while without speaking.
Maybe it won't. I dropped a step
behind and watched her face.
She always spoke to me in the voice
of an adult dispensing wisdom.
I wanted to ask her if she knew
what she thought and if so,
what the experience of that sort
of knowledge was like and if not,
whether she too felt ghostly
as I imagined she must.
This is an instance where what?
What Ruth experiences might
be said to be total identity,
a very stable identity.
She cannot alienated herself from
herself to know what she is thinking.
So if you think about that construction,
I don't know what I think it posits
and I who could know the self,
that's two entities,
not one.
So if you don't know what you think,
maybe it's because there isn't that
objective distance between an eye and a
self.
You're not self alienated in that way
that remember Ambrose always is in lost in
the fun house.
That's his curse,
that he's alienated from himself
and he can never integrate.
So it's like he's Lillian
known I in one person,
two entities,
but somehow the same roof on the other
hand is like an indivisible substance.
But because it's indivisible,
it seems,
the logic here imagines it's somehow
it's like an essence or something,
um,
on substantive because it doesn't
have that alienation built into it.
How can you exist in the company of
other people if the structure for even
knowing oneself doesn't
seem to exist in the mind?
Yeah,
there are other manifestations
that have more to do with nature.
And you can find one of
these on one 15 one 16
the bottom of one 1615 this is when
Lucille and Ruth spend the night outside.
It's one of two very important moments
when Ruth spends the night outside.
Here's one with Lucille and there'll
be one of right after the page where I
asked you to stop for today with a Sylvie.
Yeah.
For awhile she Lucille saying Mockingbird
Hill and then she sat down beside me
in our ruined stronghold.
Never still never accepting that all
our human boundaries were overrun.
Lucile would tell this story differently.
She would say,
I fell asleep,
but I did not.
I simply let the darkness in the sky
become coextensive with the darkness in my
SCO and bowels and bones,
everything that falls upon
the eye is apparition.
A sheet dropped over the
world's true workings.
The nerves and the brain are tricked
and one is left with dreams that these
specters loose their hands from hours
and walk away the curve of the back and
the swing of the coat so familiar as
to imply that they should be permanent
fixtures, fixtures of
the world. When in fact,
nothing is more perishable.
Say That my mother was as tall as a man
and that she's sometimes set me on her
shoulders so that I could splash my
hands in the cold leaves above our heads.
Say That my grandmother was saying in her
throat while she sat on her bed and we
laced up her big black shoes.
Such details are merely
accidental who could know but us.
And since their thoughts were
bent upon other ghosts than ours,
other darknesses than we had seen,
why was must we be left?
The survivors picking among flotsam among
the small unnoticed unvalued clutter
that was all that remained
when they vanished,
that only catastrophe made notable
darkness is the only solvent.
While it was dark,
despite Lucille's pacing and whistling,
and despite what must have been dreams,
since even Sylvie came to haunt me,
it seemed to me that there need not
be relic remnant margin residue,
memento, bequest, memory,
thought track or trace.
If only the darkness could
be perfect and permanent.
So Ruth Fields,
her boundaries overrun when the content
of her mind and the quality of the world
become indistinguishable.
The darkness in the mind and the body
indistinguishable from the darkness
outside her.
And this is a positive condition for her
in so far as it seems to eliminate the
need for things like memories,
traces, remnants, that
list that were given.
Now I'm going to talk much more about
the question of loss on Wednesday.
That's the theme for that
lecture on this novel.
So I'm going to leave that as
something for you to think about.
What is the status of loss in the novel?
Um,
but for now what I want to note is how
the overrun boundaries of the self is
imagined as redemptive.
So the loss of identity as
against some other outside thing,
be it nature,
another person,
another piece of the community and other
group that is idea is imagine not as a
problem but as something to be embraced.
Yeah.
These observations about
Ruth's permeability and
the general permeability of
persons one to another brings us back
to that question that I asked a little
while ago.
Where does Ruth's voice come from?
Okay.
And here.
I want to note that language is imagined
to be all mixed up with the material of
the world. If you look on page 85
you can see one example of this.
Oops,
sorry.
They think that's not the,
okay,
sorry. Yeah. Yes. This
is the one that one,
I remember Sylvia walking through the
house with a scarf tied around her hair
carrying a broom.
Yet this was the time that leaves
began to gather in the corners.
There were leaves that had
been through the winter.
Some of them worn to a net of veins.
There were scraps of paper among them,
crisp and strained. From
there, mingling in the cold,
brown liquors of decay and degenerate
and regeneration, and on these scraps,
there were some times words,
one red powers meat and another which
had been the flap of an envelope,
had a penciled message in anonymous hand.
I think of you,
perhaps Sylvie, when she swept,
took care not to molest them.
Perhaps she sensed a Delphic niceness
in the scattering of these leaves and
paper here and not elsewhere
thus and not otherwise.
Words are all bound up in
the material of the world.
The stuff that gathers in the corners of
a house and more over their words that
are very evocative powers meet as if
somehow language and leaves meeting in the
corner of a house signifies the various
powers of the cosmos coming together.
Powers meat,
I think of you and its anonymity.
It's character as coming
from an envelope flap.
The kind of piece of paper that travels
from one person to another suggests a
communicative minus,
a general intent surrounding
these pieces of matter,
leaves and paper.
So two things associated with language,
the words themselves and also
intention gather around these debris.
If that is true,
we might also think of one 26 the
dictionary full of pressed flowers.
Sin,
another beautiful image.
So Lucille has asked Ruth to look up
pinking sheers in the dictionary because
she's trying to make her dress and she
doesn't know what the pinking shears are
that are called for in the pattern.
And so she asks Ruth to look it up.
Ruth finds pressed into the flow into
the old dictionary flowers that her
grandfather has gathered,
all filed under they're alphabetical name,
and she is much more concerned with the
flowers than she is with getting the
definition of pinking shears. So here
you have two visions of language. One,
the pinking shears language.
The hoard of words is for identifying
things so you can do practical tasks.
And in this case, the practical task
is Lucille's effort to blend in with,
with the town.
Ruth's conception of language is that it
is a horde of expressive gems or part.
Well, it's not a good way
of putting it. It's um,
it's a vocabulary of the world
that includes not only words,
but also flowers
and that there are beauties of eat
all in their place in this dictionary.
So if language comes almost viscerally
from nature here we can see exactly how
Robinson is in the realm of the
19th century. Transcendentalists.
And here I'm going to read you a little
bit from Emerson's essay nature. Okay.
This is what he says about,
um, being in the woods.
Yeah.
Within these plantations of God,
a decorum and sanctity rain.
A perennial festival is dressed and the
guest sees not how he should tire of
them. In a hundred year. In a
thousand years in the woods,
we return to reason and faith there I
feel that nothing can be for me in life.
No disgrace,
no calamity leaving me my eyes,
which nature cannot repair.
Standing on the bare ground,
my head bathed by the blithe air
and uplifted into infinite space,
all mean egotism vanishes.
I become a transparent eyeball.
I am nothing.
I see all the currents of the
universal being circulate through me.
I am part or parcel of God,
the name of the nearest friend sounds
then foreign and accidental to be
brothers,
to be acquaintances,
master or servant is then
a trifle and a disturbance.
I am the lover of uncontained and
immortal beauty in the wilderness.
I find something more deer and coordinate
then in streets or villages in the
tranquil landscape and especially in
the distant line of the horizon. Man,
behold somewhat as
beautiful as his own nature.
Okay,
so the transparent eyeball I am nothing.
I see all
that is the sense you get of Ruth's voice,
that Ruth's voices like the voice
of that transparent eyeball,
the difference between Emerson's
vision and Robinsons I think is the way
Robinson is willing to
let the human environment,
the built environment,
the house become part and parcel of that
woodsy hole that Emerson so wants to
immerse himself in.
So the house is opened to leaves,
leaves are mixed up with pieces of paper
with words and so you get that sense of
a creation that is saying something to
this consciousness in the same way that
Emerson imagines,
but it can happen in a house.
She embellishes this vision
of a speaking material world.
Yeah.
So Ruth's sense of self,
okay.
Mirrors that.
Um,
that fluidity that you get
in the transparent eyeball.
There is um,
also something that you can
see. Wait, hold on. I'm trying.
I'm now trying to find my, um,
the page number that I need.
Um,
this is 16 through 19.
Here it is.
Okay.
That fluidity of consciousness that
the transparent eyeball gives you is
beautifully on display in this passage.
Um,
towards the beginning of the novel
when Ruth is thinking about how her
grandmother responded to the death of
her husband and the departure of her
daughters.
I'm not going to read this whole thing
because it would simply take too long,
but I just want to show you what
happens over these three pages.
So on the top of 16,
this is another one of
those hypothetical's.
One day my grandmother must have carried
out a basket of sheets to hang in the
spring sunlight wearing her widows black,
performing the rituals of the
ordinary as an act of faith.
Say there were two or three inches of
hard old snow on the ground with Earth
here and they're losing through the
broken places and that there was warmth in
the sunlight when the wind did not
blow it all away and say she stooped
breathlessly and her corset to lift up
a sodden sheet by its hems and say that
when she had pinned three
corners to the lines,
it began to below and leap in her hands
to flutter and tremble and to glare with
the light.
And that the throes of the thing where
as gleeful and strong as if a spirit
we're dancing in,
it's Sarah Mints that when she would say,
because it pushed the skirts of her coat
against her legs and made the strands
of her hair fly,
it came down the lake and it smelled
sweetly of snow and rankly of melting snow
and it called to mind the small scare
stemi flowers that she and Edmund would
walk half a day to pick. Did you
catch that little transition there?
Yeah.
Transition from propositions
say that this happens.
Say this is what my grandmother did
and saw and smelled to a seamless
inhabitation through that
free indirect discourse.
Ruth enters the mind of her grandmother.
Yes,
and starts to inhabit her memories of her
husband from long before the time when
Ruth was born.
Yeah.
We smell the wind with Ruth through the
grandmother and we know that it reminds
her of the flowers that she and Edmond
would pick and then you get along
meditation of the most private thoughts
that the grandmother has about her
husband and what he's
like in the springtime.
And this is at the bottom of 17 and it
concludes with this line at such times.
He's just, she's just imagined him as
a, as a primitive man rather than, um,
formal Edmond at such times.
He was as forgetful of her as he was
of his suspenders and his methodism,
but all the same. It was then
that she loved him best as a soul,
all unaccompanied, like
her own. It's that,
so all unaccompanied that most
concerns Robinson as a writer.
And here Ruth imagines of kind of free
access to that other soul that is her
grandmother.
And if you look in the middle of 18,
there's one of these amazing tents shifts.
She's going,
Ruth is going from meditating on her
early widowhood as a memory to a time,
a little less far back to the
wake of her daughter's departures,
the grandmothers,
a grief at their departure.
And now that's the now referred to in
the middle of 18 and now to comfort
herself.
My grandmother would not reflect on
the unkindness of her children or have
children in general.
She had noticed many times,
always that her girls faces were soft
and serious and inward and still when she
looked at them just as they had
been when they were small children,
just as they were now, when they were
sleeping, if a friend was in the room,
her daughters would watch his or her face
intently and t's or sued or banter and
any one of them could gauge and respond
to the finest changes of expression or
tone.
Even Sylvie if she chose to,
but it did not occur to them to suit
their words and manners to her looks and
she did not want them to.
In fact,
she was often prompted a restrained
by the thought of saving this
unconsciousness of theirs.
She was then a magisterial woman,
not only because of her height
and her large sharp phase,
not only because of her upbringing,
but also because it suited her purpose
to be what she seemed to be so that her
children would never be startled or
surprised and to take on all the postures,
investments of matron to differentiate
her life from theirs so that her children
would never feel intruded upon.
She's careful to guard their separateness
and then you get this wonderful
meditation, quite mysterious, and I
don't actually have a full account of it.
Why the grandmother finding the potatoes
in the garden comes to be a moment of
revelation. Maybe this is
something you can think about.
Why is it that specifically that detail
that Robinson chooses to make a moment
of epiphany when the grandmother says,
what have I seen? What have I seen?
The earth and the sky and the garden,
not as they always are,
and she saw her daughter's faces not
as they always were or as other peoples
were,
and she was quiet and aloof and watchful
not to start all the strangeness away.
She had never taught
them to be kind to her.
So in that three page passage,
Ruth's voice inhabits her grandmother's
mind at widely varied moments in the
grandmother's life, important,
extremely intimate moments.
Even this strange moment
of epiphany in the garden.
No one's anywhere near around different,
very mysterious kind of epiphany.
Who knows really what it means.
And yet Ruth can tell us about it.
Robinson has described her
writerly project as giving
us access to the kinds of
things that people
would say if they could.
And I just want to read you
this quotation from Robinson.
One of the primary mistakes people make
is to take people spoken language to be
equivalent to the level of their thinking.
I think it's one of the oddest errors.
What she takes herself to be doing is to
be providing for Ruth's mind a language
that can match the flexibility of
this young person's consciousness,
its range,
its permeability,
and also in that very supple
voice to be her identity.
So the voice becomes who Ruth is.
So no matter how far she ranges
across her boundaries of person,
no matter how indistinct the darkness
in her mind is from the darkness outside
her body,
that voice can still be heard and
it can still be identified as hers,
even as it ranges in and out
of her grandmother's thoughts,
in and out of Sylvie's thoughts,
in and out of Lucile's thoughts,
in and out of her mother's thoughts.
So that in the end is what constitutes
something like identity in this novel.
Now on Wednesday,
in the very short time I will have,
I'll talk about what that voice has
to do with the question of loss,
which haunts this novel in every sentence.
As I'm sure you've noticed,
very Ella giant sense to this novel.
So I'm going to reconcile this argument
that I've made today with an analysis of
what that is doing in the novel.